[Musik]
er ist 17 jahre politisch
sie sind mit ausbildung und damit auch
die grenze
dabei soll
[Musik]
jetzt passiert wie so häufig im alltag
vom fcp von der polizei basel landschaft
wie viel hat der alltag mit der
vorstellung verschiedener junge
kolleginnen und kollegen zur uno im
brief steht
und dann habe der unbekannte plötzlich
eine waffe zu
bestaunen 1000 kommt auch der mann
verstarb die frau abholen dann hätte
kontakt kommt mein großer mal zwei meter
groß rote jacke schwarzes baseballcap
und schwarze jogginghose und hatte eine
waffe zogen roth
bedrohte mann mit der waffe in dem
moment weitere personen
[Musik]
jugendliche von herrn die fußball guckt
und sich
fragen
außerdem halten wir euch schon bald noch
größer war gauck und so weiter kontakt
ta unternehmer und alles wieder gut
sein
dass man da hören sonst nach
[Musik]
wo ich einmal mit der waffe
resega
[Musik]
ich schaffe und filmpartner fahrendem
auto mit
speziell dafür die frage ob ole und nach
zeigte mainz oder vogel und zu hoffen
dass wir den grund
irgendwie geld vortrag macht es also
es ist nicht ganz
spurlos verschwunden
[Musik]
golland polizei basel-landschaft und sie
biete die konten aus zentral und
nordwestschweiz ihren nachwuchs
ausbilden
die sogenannte crowd woche berufen
programm vor der user wirklich kennt
viele größere sparte
nervös gespannt was seine worte die als
nun ins wasser gelangt aber es wird ein
gemeinschaftliches oxid aber
zuversichtlich dass das klappt
konzentrieren das wird langsam wie schon
bei mancher fahrer schlug der
rekordmeister
und einfach mitgekommen sind
[Musik]
wertlos
[Applaus]
[Musik]
doch gott vorsortierten unterwegs als
zwei meter tief erholen
szenario puppe start für das vierte jahr
als michael wo es wasser krieg und am
trinken ist
[Musik]
denn an so wirklich musterland bringen
ein funkspruch aufsetzen und dann sofort
mit der wiederbelebung
der vierjährige war sehr kritisch war
ziemlich vom 20 von dem fuß so erhaltet
ihr die holen jetzt
wo ich tore habe ich sie also ich darf
mir schon nicht unterschätzt das kalte
wasser da wir gerade meint ich was ich
eigentlich dank dass ich besser unter
kontrolle hat schnupfen aber gerade im
moment hat schon gemerkt wie die stocker
hat mich
und sagt so jetzt muss
ich erst noch die konvektion
und
genau
das trifft
mit ok
[Musik]
für täterin noch stierli ist colt
austria bietet doch durch
die ehre ich mit der wurm drin oktober
wo sie sein roller erwischt sie nicht
mehr stand
stierli ist transrapid traumatische
erfahrung
und ich bin
glaube ich
brauche
einfach nicht tot ist also jetzt
was passiert ich schaffe das nicht so es
sind so viel gedanken mich auf der
wiese mache ich das jetzt
und juden sind also habe ich in einem
kleinen saal des stoffes ist
es in der jahn stelle ihrer aufdruckt
die familie hat aus harrislee
große bekannt die 22-jährige wo sonst
immer so souverän wirkt die grenze
braucht
nicht im griff haben sich nicht gern
doch gern im griff man kann nicht alles
perfekt meistert jeder hat seine
schwächen und ich finde es schön wenn
man sie nicht zeigen
das bin ich jetzt eine gut und es ist
wichtig zu erkennen dass meine situation
weiß helmut zum spaßen oder
[Musik]
diana staehly ich für das verlängere
zwischen andi ist es ihn kreist zusammen
mit ihrem partner wo sich noch gut an ob
ich noch der autor erinnert
dass da zwei videos sind wir nicht so
witzig und wenn ich mir dass diese show
geladen habe und ich sehe wie sie du
dir das zu untergegangen ist mechaniker
und so möglich begriffe wie er holt das
wasserbett unbeweglich und
schockiert sie
dank
ihrer völlig falsche wort
ich habe momentan eigentlich könnte
besser vorbereiten oder
irgendwas nehmen dort wo alles
vorbereitet aber immerhin trete seit
jahren still ich noch sehr gewichtig für
politik
oder interkantonale polizeischule
hitzkirch trainiert einander wirklich
schon sein kollege hütte satz vom
sogenannten grade ii satz stück holz
wichtige punkt und ich muss mich ist der
gs diagonal platziere horizontaler blogs
gefahr dass mappus berief das schwere
verletzungen zu folgen haben was mir
nicht wand sondern mit den diagonal
platzieren und den diagonal und
stoßen einander wintrich lernt wie immer
physische qualität setzt gleichzeitig
muss es später im ernstfall nicht genau
abschätzen was verhältnismäßig ist
fehleinschätzung sind fatale folgen für
ihn und für andere
viel zu schwere verletzungen oder sogar
zum tod führen in der auseinandersetzung
oder spinne heftig
und ganz wichtig und der staat bei einem
lehrer mit lina mir probiert der gäste
aber nicht um jeden preis waren die
ausprobieren und dem ärgerte sich heute
und
märz verdiente nation zu machen die
geschichte
berufen
aber wenn sie es doch braucht man
separat sie
ja ganz klar
wie muss ein euro pro jahr zur schule
fit ist es wieder soweit
shows
bestand der hat 140
mehr die blick nicht besteuert die
angeordnete es auf
meiner seite habe ich eine des direktors
test läuft gewaltig da ist schon ein
ausbau nicht ich weiß dass ich hier so
was ist mir im
ernstfall selection
7.50 noch gestellt
doch wer schon einmal da war
zum glück nehmen sind ist auch mit den
stoffen
wie jetzt natürlich mit da muss ein
anderer sein oder was ist wenn ihr das
wenn ich das brauche aber insgeheim
hofft man dass man sie natürlich näher
in die erfahrung dass nicht er fertig
machte dass man das aber sicherlich
nicht abnahme ist also da musst du mit
dem gesetz in konflikt zahl bleiben oder
sogar
tötet dann ist das psychisch mental
natürlich esa geschickt und verarbeiter
aber juristisch natürlich wird das
aufgearbeitet in der schweiz schiesst
polizeiseite wer schießt er ihm mit
einbau im knast heißt sonderpolizisten
ok
oder polizeischutz kirch trainiert
baselbieterin jona stierli und ihr
kollege hat für die ultimative
eskalationsstufe
meine gebäude hat ein amokläufer oder
ein terrorist angefangen schüsse wer
zuerst vor ort ich muss die briefe
selbst gefärbt nämlich um sekunde bist
spezialeinheit und ich
die augen der polizistinnen und
polizisten trainieren verschiedene
formationen
ident bietet sie im ernstfall vor luke
hauptverdiener stelle ihre ausbildung
von theoretisch hafen praktischer
sehr viel
im ernstfall müssten anderweitig und
sein kollege versuchte amokläufer oder
der terrorist so schnell wie möglich
stellen und zuschüsse gibt
für den ratgeber
was ihr nicht nur haut politik
wann wenn nicht jetzt hinter diesen
fortschritt wo das spiel an tina und
aspiranten die letzte minute gemacht hat
sind offensichtlich
die neue themen wie
die briefe woche wohnenden jungen meines
erachtens der spieler seine figur die
basis und jetzt kurz denn die komplexe
fall zum lösungs situationen
wahrscheinlichkeit dass etwas gebrochen
ist aber nicht nur
umso größer ist muss man jederzeit
fähigkeit ttg eskalationsstufe
bewältigen könne im richtigen moment
könne das leben
richtig funktionieren das richtige mache
bereits fähigkeit auch natürlich im
richtigen moment oder in der meisten
momenten möglichst lange dezember und um
damit sich flugs machen und in jedem
geraden
terroristisch genau das problem war
relativ kontrollen entziehen bei uns
motivieren gestoppt hatten die
wanderfreunde also für mich allein
erledigt
personalien
werden
der schwarzfahrer seite von nigeria wo
needs italien psyche groth freundes
frankreich und wähle in der schweiz
der grund sich aus erledigt und schön
geworden nachtschicht bliebt
unspektakulär
er lernt klocke
da wohne handwerker jugendliche
reklamiert
was ist der größte teil sind tolle sache
gerade jetzt ist so man natürlich
glitzern empfindliche sie langsam
erkennen sie die junge war und jetzt
kommen wir durch die meldung aber da war
und ich habe bestanden ist vorbei die
sich an frauen die jugendarbeit sei
wisse wann
im eshop wie es im alltag ganz viel um
bordelle und nur selten um leben und tod
bisher als polizist eine eher stille hat
sergio vergangen
er und sie in die patrone partnerin sind
zum haus von frau geschickt wurde
plötzlich nimmt auch vergangen ist
und haben dann die dürre weise sprache
der ganze comicszene
christ was ich erwartet meine kollegin
hat die fehler mache und der ist nun ein
überkleben
wir sagen gegen gold und das ist schon
sehr gruselig see und
sei ungewohnt natürlich habe meine
christ durch die ganze welt vor allem
was einen erwartet also etwas was kann
passieren
vom anblick das schlimmste aber es ist
nicht der mensch und der schweiz
um sich situationen der polizeischule
hitzkirch einander wirklich und kollegin
sind patrouille vor ort geschickt wird
also
gewisse etwas landschaft wird euch mit
namen sagen was ist passiert
stimmt wir
haben alles abgesperrt und erwartet
weiterhin auf ihren
vergrößern auch im jetzigen zeitpunkt
ist liegt
eigentlich sichergestellt zuhanden von
staat und der stadt untersucht der
leichnam und stellt fest spuren von
patrick die weltkrieg dose oder
irgendetwas
muss quasi untersucht auch muss klagt
sie nach der inspektion die denn die tat
muss quasi unter todeszeitpunkt muss
vielleicht ja schon tot ich sehe aber
dass ich im zusammenhang mit der
verstorbene familienmitglied wo man dann
hatten wir das letzte mal tränen
abschied aber es ist mit hanni nanni
alkoholkonsum ihr schon eine flasche im
bett lagen
jetzt - nach mögliche
variante sicher was
immer vom schlimmen störungs
wenn der vom stellungskrieg weil der
jenny verhandelt machen seit der hörer
gesetzt
nachdem sterile rolle spielt jetzt ins
gesicht
psychologe von der kantonspolizei bern
zeigt einander wirklich und seine
kollegen bilder verlieren wo man schwer
an vertrauen von menschen wo sich zum
beispiel verschossen oder ruft einstand
was jetzt aber kommt aus was mit den
personen und traurig aber suizid darüber
fordern vom zog
ohne dass schönes bild
grosse
txl also es verrückt
und ich was mache ich mir gedanken wenn
es gehäuft zu putzen und
im polizisten schalker 47 müsse kürzel
war hier
mit blaulicht organisationen
mit herbrand schwarzen humor
genau das gehört so verarbeitet gehört
zur psychohygiene das ist für ihn bietet
befreien jetzt war sie auch ganz wichtig
ist die sprüche dürfte schumacher habe
die müssten überlegen wo und in welchem
rahmen
der sensiblen messi messi name so
genannte todesnachrichten überbringen
szenario
berufen fussgängerstreifen
verkehrsunfall passiert fußgänger
fußgängerin ist auf dem
fussgängerstreifen von motorradfahrer
wurde
die person ist es so schwer verletzt
wurde dass sie auf der unfallstelle
gestorben ist
die reduzierung anhand vertrieb
identitätskarte das ist womöglich
für ihre mit dem hermelin ich hier wohne
hier
was ist passiert vor der polizei aus
landschaft
ich hab mich sehr mit ihnen unterhalten
hoffentlich
macht
also der grund wo menowin herr müller
hat sich eine halbchance unfall ereignet
die frage
ist eine
schwere verletzung erlitten und ich muss
sagen noch am unfallort verstorben
ist
[Musik]
die
aussprache und die
reaktion war
die person nicht
toten
wichtig und dass ich verdammt schwer das
jetzt noch mal 2 minuten also ist schon
der richtige ansatz zu verfolgen
dies nicht negativ
skulski naja also todesnachricht
überbringen auch grundsätzlich bei uns
mitarbeiten die wo die funktion hin und
setzen auf dann aber ich war schon der
weg soll das überbringen
klar das ist nicht schön und und
versucht natürlich möglichst sagte und
das alles geregelt werden muss man
aussprechen und sagen und das braucht
viel zeit
zum sollen viele fragen oder warum wieso
weshalb die fassungslosigkeit im ersten
moment und und hier um macht und dann
sollte auch möglichst empathisch sie und
und den eltern zu unterstützen daher
schwierige situation
der eshop wie seit als polizisten sie
mehr lerne sich abzugrenzen und
gleichzeitig der firma net abstumpfen
jeder mensch habe er geschichte und wir
müssen mit dem fall auf ein junger mann
wo bestraft worden ist
[Musik]
nachdem teilte
simpson 25
und hautfalten schon ja aus
der maske
das tor ist wie so was ist gut was
in uns haben
zweimal und einmal der
[Musik]
ganze aufwand nach 17 franken
wird täglich in einer halbzeit bevor die
schweiz wird
30 mal soviel zusammengestohlen ist
natürlich nicht aber die person haben
oder ist das tempo und haben
festgestellt dass noch andere delikte
schon passiert sind also es ist nicht
einfach da erst die falter ihm und er
dankt das geht einfach nicht da muss man
ein zeichen setzen
sitzt
das flugzeug kommen am ende kann ja auch
wenn du nicht was andere für ein
nettoeinkommen
ein schweizer franken keine angaben
natürlich verschiedene menschen oder
verschiedene optionen auf polizei
gewisse werte sind sehr anständig aber
gewisse die du in deiner karriere das
vorgehen der polizei und da muss man
einfach den zeigt aber wie system läuft
und darauf bestehen durch staat und dann
haben wir miteinander schaffen
extra lang noch so alles richtig
gestellt und da haben unsere spende
so also mehr hat dann alles anders geht
zeigen die staatsanwaltschaft oder
treibt
uns eben alle phasen der ausgaben aber
weil böse wort von nico aber das ist auf
lager halten
möge das war doch eine macht aber das
bringt doch nochmal herumdreht unserem
kloster vorstellen
[Musik]
denn an der wirklich ist eine
einmonatige praktikum es im polizeikorps
das geht er zur ursachenklärung sonntag
fällt da haben jetzt amerika und so
packt ihr selber immer wieder gern und
dennis stück wird unsere pflicht dass
das halt auf der straße entsprechend
herrscht der augen die polizist kant
kreis pardon
ich will so gut wie möglich zu jung so
viel wie möglich mit möglichst viel zu
lernen wird aus benito und die vier
wochen sind begrenzt und da muss jede
gelegenheit nutzen um alles mit navas
polizisten zwölf sich aneinander wie am
ersten tag und der polizei schulzeit
wurde de maizière sie entwickeln ein
wolf ja das ist schwierig zu sagen
langsam aber sicher
diana staehly die andere junge wölfin
patroulliert kauf der porträtierte
straße
sie wählt aus verstärkung für traffic
von verehrte hinter gefordert
so gott hinter dem hageren 80 gesetze so
groß die variante familien alpinen sehen
und wenn sie das spaziergang machte
casey überhaupt seinem streitbaren
terminieren ab und schlossen an der
sonne so zusammen und bringe sehr
wohl behütete dazu
hier heute nicht erst mal besondere
anderen achte ungefähr
hatte ist auch grundsätzlich offen für
eine
verhaltensregel blockieren
wenn du jetzt noch hat ich habe
keinerlei regung dass man sich wieder
besser fahren
plan ist es das wert der aktien vor dem
york kelly um geboren und lauter
demnächst ihren widerruf bedeuten
warnte im zelt im idealfall zurück
braucht werte zu ihrer mutter damit sie
nicht vom nächsten fuß größer werde
er hatte an der familie
und eine
wirtschaftliche konzentrationen die
chance dass sinnvolle angestellt und bei
uns hatten stiegen und
die häufig verzehrt
obwohl ich gesagt perfekt
[Musik]
genau durchsucht so genannte
424 bedeutet fahren in angetrunkenem
zustand
immer das heißt kontrolle gerne
immer wieder überraschen wer hat recht
die kontrolle und ich weiß nie genau was
auf ihn zukommt und
ios fordert einmal sehr viel gespür ab
finde ich halte erkenne ich schätze wird
personen gegenüber ich werde sie
vielleicht apps dunkelheit oder
ein junger kollege michael tesch mit
online händler verletzte schlug
schon mal machen
dann müssen sie wissen schon eher
wichtig ist ohne unterbruch für uns
achsen und getrieben stellt mit einem
fest ich absolut aus
0,35
die grauen projekt habe 0,7 promille
ganze spiel 0,4 promille
wird es schwierig sagt jetzt nochmals
wissen
jetzt ist es so dass ich jetzt hier
zeigt wie man so schön sagt
das heißt er von dem wieder fahren und
es gibt derzeit staatsanwaltschaft
wenn es so war eigentlich schon sagen
dann bin ich selber überrascht herr
kollege bereits schönes dokument vorher
also
dass du heute mit die website werden
könne dort also das heißt ihrem fall wo
sie bis zu 0,4 und sie ist noch einmal
kleiner wenn sie sagen jawohl der wert
von einer 0,35 messer hat der kec wenn
sie sehr gut nein da müssen wir für broz
tito
bewiesen hat michael meeske
möglichkeit zur blutprobe verlangen wenn
sie das lied
das ist schon okay ich akzeptiere das so
wenn sie mir da als diener machen und
dann unterschrieben
unterschrieben ja
danke schön
er muss es auto steuern und die worte
der sonett abholt
ich finde es immer gefährlich wenn ein
lied alkoholisierte autofahrer und ich
finde generell dass man
dringend dass man sollte einfach einmal
lang und das logo
von damals und ich kein mitleid wäre
fatal genug seid also damit gerechnet
dass der busfahrer und dann finde ich
das falsche risiko jedoch nicht
und so gott will
aufschluss briefe der polizei
schaffen sie es oder nicht
das kann man ins spiel
[Musik]